المترجم: Sara Sibai
المدقّق: Allam Zedan
لقد بدأ كلّ شيء عندما علمنا أن زوجتي حامل
كنت سأصبح أبًا!
من منّا لا يتذكّر هذه اللحظة المميّزة ؟
خاصة مع أوّل طفل...
كلّ ما أعرفه عن الأولاد وعن تربية الأولاد
مرّ في ذهني في تلك اللحظة
ومن هناك، بدأت الرحلة:
دهشة، ترقّب، وتشويق.
وكان بطن زوجتي يختمر كالعجينة،
وكان طفلنا يكبر شيئًا فشيئًا،
وأتابعه بالتصوير
بالموجات فوق الصوتية من حين لآخر.
ولا زلت أتذكّر أوّل مرّة أحسست به يركل،
وأتذكر جيّدًا لحظة الحقيقة
لمعرفة جنس الجنين: طرة أم نقشة؟
وتبيّن أنه صبي!
وخلال هذه الفترة،
كنت أطالع كلّ كتاب تقع عليه يداي
عن تربية الأولاد.
ومع أن طفولتي كانت سعيدة،
كنت مصرّا أن هناك طريقة أفضل للتربية.
من غير المسموح
أن يكون ابني غير مبالٍ أو مهملًا
مثل كثير من أولاد أناس أعرفهم.
وكانت تخطر ببالي أفكار وصور
عن تصرفاتي معه عندما يولد.
كنت أريد أن أقوم بكل ما قمت به في صغري
وأمور أخرى لم تتح لي فرصة القيام بها.
وبعد تسعة أشهر، نضجت الطبخة!
وانتهت الأمور على خير ما يرام.
وكان شعورًا لا يوصف عندما رأيته،
وحملته لأوّل مرّة.
ومرورًا بأوّل ضحكة، لأوّل حبوة، لأوّل سنّ،
لأوّل مرّة قصصت فيها شعره،
مررنا بمرحلة جميلة جدًا...
وكان أمتع وقت حين يقهقه
"كتكوت"، هكذا كنت أغنجه.
كنت غارقًا حتى رأسي!
كنت سأكون أروع أب في العالم،
أليس كذلك؟
ممكن نعم، وممكن لا!
تدريجيًا، انشغلت بهموم الحياة
وتهت عن الأب الخارق الذي كنت أتخيّله،
وصارت صور الأمور التي
كنت أريد تحقيقها معه تتلاشى
صورة تلو الأخرى.
مرحبًا بابا،
ألن تتناول معي العشاء هذه الليلة؟
صرت أتأخّر في دوام المكتب
حتى أيّام السبت،
وأسافر أحيانًا خلال عطلة
نهاية الأسبوع للعمل.
وكتيرًا لم أكن متواجدًا بقربه
عندما ينام.
بالطبع، كنت أعتقد أن كل ما كنت أفعله
كان في مصلحة العائلة
وفي مصلحة ابني بالذات،
وكيف لا،
ويجب عليّ أن أضمن له أفضل تعليم،
وأفضل نشاطات متنوعة ومتفرقة
لتنمية الشخصيّة!
وكنت من وقت لآخر،
أقرأ كتابًا أو أشاهد محاضرة عن التربية،
وكنت أفكّر في نفسي:
يجب أن أطبّق شيئًا
مما أطّلع عليه بأقرب وقت،
ولكن في أغلب الأيام،
لم يكن يحصل أي شيء،
وكان يراودني إحساس بالذنب...
سرعان ما كنت أطرده من ذهني.
بصورة عامة، كانت الأمور تسير بشكل مقبول،
وصارت هذه الأمور جزءًا من الحياة اليومية.
اعتدت على هذا الوضع،
اعتدنا كلنا على مثل هذا الوضع.
وفجأة،
أصبح عمر ابني... ست سنوات!
لم أصدّق!
كيف أصبح في السادسة من عمره!
فمنذ فترة وجيزة كنّا لم نزل في أوّل حبوة
وأول سن و... كيف مرّ كل هذا الوقت؟
ما أكثر الأشياء التي كنت
أريد أن أقوم بها معه!
يقال أن أوّل ست سنوات هي الأهمّ...
هل يعقل أن أكون قد أضعت
أهمّ فرصة في حياتي، كأب؟
انشغلت بمشاريع من كل حدب وصوب،
وغاب عن بالي أن ابني هو أهم مشروع.
وماذا بعد؟
هل سأنتظر ست سنوات أخرى
حتى أعود إلى صوابي؟
وفي تلك اللحظة أدركت،
أدركت أنني إذا لم أغيّر شيئًا
في أقرب وقت،
سأضيّع أيضًا السنوات القادمة.
وقرّرت أن أغيّر شيئًا!
أكيد، لم يحصل التغيير بين ليلة وضحاها.
مرّ بعض الوقت
قبل أن أعيد ترتيب وقتي وأولويّاتي،
ومنذ ذلك الحين،
عدت للتركيز على علاقتي مع ابني،
وعادت كل تلك الصور، أوضح وأجمل من قبل.
بابا، هل يمكننا قراءة "الأمير الصغير"
قبل أن أنام؟
WOW! لن تذهب إلى العمل هذا السبت؟
هل يمكننا الذهاب إلى كورنيش البحر؟
وهكذا صرت أعود إلى البيت باكرًا،
وآخذ إجازة أيّام السبت،
وصرنا نقوم بأمور أعادتني لطفولتي...
صرنا نبتكر أشياءً ونخترعها
من كل ما قد يقع تحت أيدينا.
مثلا وجدنا مرّة floppy disks (أقراص مرنة)
أتذكروها؟ كانت منسيّة في جارور،
فقرّرنا أن نقوم بإعادة تدويرها
وصنعنا منها أشكالًا غريبة عجيبة!
وتذكّرت كيف كنت أحب أن أختبئ
تحت طاولة الطعام وأنا طفل،
فحددنا لنا ركنًا في الخزانة،
يمكننا أن نقرأ ونختبئ فيه سويّا
وحتى النقّيفة (المجنقة)...
صعدت إلى العليّة وبحثت عنها ثم أخرجتها
وأعدنا تأهيلها.
من ناحية ثانية، جرّبت حظّي مع Minecraft
ولكن بحسب ابني... ما زلت في أول الطريق
و ينقصني الكثير.
وأصبح عندنا عاداتنا الخاصة:
أمرّ عليه أحيانًا من المدرسة
ونذهب لأكل المثلجات.
ويوم الجمعة
بات عندنا يومًا للفيلم الأسبوعي
وطبعًا مع الفوشار!
وصار يخبرني عن الأمور
التي يحبّ أن يقوم بها معي،
وكانت عنده لائحة تطول وتطول
وكانت عنده أسئلة،
الكتير من الأسئلة!
بابا، لماذا لا يقع القمر على الأرض؟
ولماذا لا تغرق الغواصة؟
والعصفور الواقف على سلك كهربائي...
لماذا لا يصعق بالكهرباء؟
وغصت بالعلوم من جديد.
ومع كل تفسير، كنت أبتسم
كلما رأيت الدهشة في عينيه.
وكان لا بدّ من السؤال الشهير:
بابا، من أين يأتي الأولاد؟
من الملفوفة، أكيد!
وفاجأني أحيانًا بأسئلة من نوع آخر، مثل:
بابا، كيف بدأ الكون؟
ولماذا هناك حروب؟
ولماذا هناك أناس فقراء؟
ولم يكن دائما لديّ الجواب....
وصرنا نبحث في مواضيع
لم أتوقّع أن تهمّه في هذا العمر
مثل مرض الزهايمر، إدارة الأموال،
وعن التغيير والمجازفة ومنطقة الأمان،
وحتى عن الانتخابات الأخيرة.
وكلما سنحت الفرصة،
نتكلّم عن القيم المهمّة، مثلًا:
كان يقدّم عرض breakdance منذ أسبوع،
فتكلّمنا عن المجازفة والانضباط الذاتي
وعن أهمية المثابرة والانجاز.
كلّها أسئلة ومواضيع كنت نسيتها لفترة،
جعلتني أفكّر مجدّدًا
وأنتبه للأمور المهمّة.
ومن ناحية أخرى،
أردت أن أكون قريبًا من محيطه التعليمي،
فتحمّست وتطوّعت في لجنة الأهل،
وبادرت بأكثر من مشروع،
وكانت تجربة غنيّة جدًا بالنسبة لي.
ولم يكن باستطاعتي أن أحاضر بالمجازفة
دون أن أجازف شخصيًا،
فقمت بأخذ المبادرة بتحضيرهذا ال TEDx talk
وكانت تجربة مميّزة،
طوّرَت كتيرًا علاقتي مع ابني،
كما أنّه ساعدني قليلًا بالتحضير.
الآن، لا أقول أن كلّ شيء على ما يرام
على الدوام، وأنّه ليس هناك تقلّبات،
وأنّي لا أتمنّى القيام بالمزيد
من الأعمال معه في بعض الأيام،
ولكنني أقصد أن أعمل كل ما في وسعي
كي نستمتع ونستفيد من كل يوم يمر.
وأنتم، يمكن أن تكون ظروفكم مختلفة،
والمرحلة التي وصلتم إليها مختلفة،
وطريقتكم مختلفة، لكن لا تنتظروا!
لا تنتظروا الى حين تتفاجؤون
وقت يأتي يوم تخرّج أولادكم،
فتنظرون إلى الوراء، وتتساءلون بصدمة:
"معقول؟! كيف ضاعت كل هذه السنين؟"